please please keep up with me James go
as fast as you can
[Applause]
hi I I'm Ellen degenerous sorry but
you don't really look like Ellen
degenerous to me you're probably a
little nervous cuz you're a you're a big
fan you've uh come to my taping before
yeah you you and your exgirlfriend
didn't you yeah we went how do you know
that well get in the car Tom we can talk
about it in private it's not a a
limousine well I I like a Lincoln why
the would you like a Lincoln come on
don't be a car snob just just get in the
car I'm not a car snob why would you
like a Linn over a
limo get in the car the J from TV she's
giving away
gifts happened to you man I got hit in
the face oh well that's what happens
when you go too fast here give me a hand
you got to keep up with me man did you
say Ellen degenerous was here no that
wasn't Ellen degenerous it was a
murderer you what how's it look awful
wipe your
[Music]
mouth